hours equivalent to more than 130 days
that's four full months this year alone
with no power
South Africa is in the throes of an
electricity crisis
and with some of the worst Inner City
crime rates in the world the lack of
light is lethal
because it's dark and we've got more
robberies that are happening we've got
more burglaries that are happening we've
got more complaints that are just coming
in
a record number of assault cases have
been reported to the police in the worst
year of blackout so far the dark Corners
have become a cover for criminals
in Alexandria one of johannesburg's more
dangerous townships the community has
taken it upon themselves to police the
streets
your radius should be on all the time
it's just crazy that they're doing this
with no arms with no protection with all
these Alleyways where people could jump
out and attack them knowing very well
that these are the people tasked with
protecting the community against Crime
the power Cuts euphemistically called
load shedding have made a hard job even
harder there's like so much unemployment
going on
in in in in Alexandra at the moment that
it's just chaotic you know what I mean
so anybody would do anything for you
know for anything it makes it really
really hard to keep it safe so now load
shedding comes in and it's just like you
know 50 harder all of a sudden our
government they don't they just they
only care about our votes but when
coming to to power Cuts they don't care
because they're only living in their
suburbs I know some of them they
experience these podcasts but they are
their houses are well secured they've
got security guards so here we don't
have security cards we only have
ourselves to protect ourselves
and for the lucky few when the lights go
off the generators go on
South Africa's power utility s-com has
been implementing the highest level of
electricity Cuts yet leaving people with
no power for at least five hours a day
escom blames an aging Fleet of coal-fart
stations that constantly break down
struggling to generate even half of
their capacity
even in the daylight residents are
recovering from the nighttime Cuts so
the street lights go off yeah they do
so you've always lived here on the
street zotila and Carla was assaulted on
her way home from work
the attackers didn't just take her phone
they kicked her pregnant belly they
wrote me my phone actually that guy he
was
he came
at the pick the other one he was looking
in front of me so I felt like my I lost
my baby then yeah it was a little bit
traumatizing
but I hate to be strong to save my child
then that's when I survived
we're praying for everything we're
praying for everything that is happening
in this country
[Music]
hope is clearly not enough
when the lights are back on and the
music plays for a moment there's joyful
relief
Johannesburg